This is how Ghulam Hassan Dar remembers his
son Adil before he disappeared last year.
Last month, a car packed with explosives rammed
a convoy of Indian paramilitary troops, killing
more than 40.
The blast - just a few miles from here - shook
the family’s home.
Ghulam Dar then received news that the suicide
bomber had been his own son.
“We were shocked.
We didn’t think he could ever do something
like this.
Everyone started crying..
Who can take pride in this?
So many people have died.”
The Dar family says Adil joined mass street
protests in 2016.
He was injured and bedridden for months.
He lost a year of college.
“My son went to help a protestor who was
hit by a bullet.
But, he was also shot in the leg by security
forces.
He couldn’t get over the incident…
he didn’t talk to us about it but he was
seething with anger every time he saw the
military.”
It’s a situation Ghulam Dar says is all
too common in the region.
The family lost contact with Adil last year.
“We knew he had become a militant.
We tried to find him.
But we couldn’t…
We can’t raise our voice here.
The military and police make arrests and torture
people.
It forces people to resist.
That’s why young people want to join the
militants.
Everybody wants to pick up a gun.
It wasn’t only my child.
Even well educated young people are joining
the movement…
“We are not terrorists, our children are
not terrorists, military personnel are not
terrorists.
It’s politicians who are the terrorists.”
An armed insurgency against Indian rule first
began here in 1989.
Though far smaller now, authorities say it’s
increasingly drawing local recruits like Adil
Dar.
They come from villages like this one in the
southern part of the Kashmir valley, considered
a hotbed of militancy.
Official figures show last year alone, security
forces killed more than 250 militants in the
region.
Since the recent escalation in tensions between
India and Pakistan, the Indian army has intensified
its crackdown here.
In recent years, the rise of the Hindu nationalist
BJP party and their tough approach to the
region has also stoked fears in the predominantly
Muslim Kashmir Valley.
Many here yearn for independence from what
they see as oppressive Indian rule.
At the district court in Srinagar, the capital
of Indian-administered Kashmir…
lawyer Mir Urfi defends teenagers arrested
for protesting or providing logistical support
for alleged militants.
Their basic rights she says aren’t protected,
fueling resentment and anger.
“Once a person is arrested, he is to be
explained why he is arrested, he is to be
given access to family members, he is to be
given access to legal aid.
All these things are denied to him.
He’s kept in police station for days together,
for months together without any remand, without
producing him before a magistrate…”When
they see these things and ask ‘why am I
not being treated like a normal person?
Today, the city of Srinagar has shut down
after a strike called by separatist groups.
It’s an all too common sight in the Kashmir
Valley.
For young people here, it’s almost impossible
to have a normal life.
“We miss lessons when schools close down
because of the strikes.
Our mothers worry we might get hit by a bullet
if we go out.”
“Everyone, I can assure you, everyone has
this anger that their movements are hindered
everywhere.
They cannot go.+++
With India and Pakistan on high alert following
the recent tensions, people in Indian-controlled
Kashmir are bracing for more protests, strikes
and violence - further inflaming a conflict
that has already been smouldering for decades.